are you a fan of trump
um
are you a supporter
of yes okay yes so what did he run on
trade and and uh trade and
immigration did he run on pro-life
no no and that was an error but but wait
a minute that was an error but but no
it's not an error no it was well let me
let me challenge you let me challenge
you let me challenge you here okay
so you're an april 10 baby right yeah
okay my dad's an april 10th baby and i
love april babies i hire april babies
okay to me they're very
true believers in what they're in and
they stick to it right okay i lived with
that man for 43 years okay so it's a lot
of strong values that he has okay
so trump ran on what he ran on
the wall okay he ran on
he drained our swamp okay all three so
look look at this guy on what he ran on
and you would have liked for him to run
on pro-life
you would have liked for him to run on
faith god you would you would have liked
for him to render all those things
absolutely okay let me ask you a
question what just happened to roe v
wade
um
we took a good step in the right
direction how did that happen
the supreme court stood up and grew up
who picked those three supreme court
donald trump
would he have done that if his messaging
was hardcore only pro-life he wouldn't
have won
so so the message i'm trying to make is
some because it's all pure strategy
so the strategy isn't that he
he may have done something impossible
three it drove them insane they lost
their minds that may be the single
biggest victory a president's ever had
people today are sitting there saying
holy [ __ ] i thought being a president
mattered
no
it's supreme court because you got you
got six three now five four whatever
it's gonna end up being for how many
years are you kidding me so maybe power
to him for strategy that's all i'm
saying i'm not saying compromise your
values i'm not saying compromise what
you believe in i'm just saying messaging
is
where i think like for example today
okay republicans who cry
uh
and at the same time cry yeah
republicans who cry like john boehner
type occurs but there's a no no there's
a lot of no no left right
anywhere you go you go boehner cry
you go uh uh you know mega you go
lincoln project you go
uh uh whoever you go to who's like cry
like cry foul or actually crying tears
well listen isn't forbes for sale
isn't forbes for sale for 6 30
how many republicans have gone and made
an offer of 400 million to see if they
can buy forbes if somebody on the left
buys it you deserve everything they do
when they announce woman of the year
award forbes magazine last year
international woman of the year award
you know what they give it to hillary
clinton you deserve it you're telling me
you can't spend 400 million dollars to
buy forbes every time these media
companies that go on sale why don't you
go buy
props to daily wire for what they're
doing which is you know the the the
uh uh
shapiro on his guy george
props to these guys that are doing what
they're doing tim paul props to there's
a lot of these names that we can give to
they're going out there pushing the
envelope but if you don't like that your
argument's not being heard do something
about it and by the way they're doing
something about it royce my opinion
is a 20-year solution it's not a one
year no it takes 20 years so put put
your money where your mouth is
not you anybody in the market that's got
the millions or you really care about
america you really care about your
conservative beliefs they're not they're
not real conservatives then then that's
the problem yeah no and yeah no i agree
with you 100 percent no
most of my campaign has been to speak
out against the republican establishment
or the conservative movement as a whole
from an ideological standpoint even from
a strategic standpoint
there's no way that liberalism has run
off with a with the lion's share control
of the mainstream media without the
conservative or prominent conservatives
or powerful or or conservatives that are
in a position to actually affect
these industries there's no way that
they did that
um
by chance
it didn't just happen they were in on it
they were always you know but that is
the unit party so for me to not be able
to say uniparty in the public square out
of fear of people not knowing what it is
or comprehending it as they would a a
more palatable issue uh uh really
strikes against the deficit that i see
in in time to solve this issue and it
may be 20 years but then we've got to
get started with the truth one million
percent yeah
and trump should have ran trump should
have ran on pro-life yeah
he not singularly
but i do believe that as a leader of a
movement
um it is your duty to to hold and plant
flags and be able to merge the message
together in a way that you could go back
to later even even though he didn't he
did more for the pro-life movement the
last 30 years than any other president
who ran on pro-life did so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]